the cubs try and go for the sweep
looking for back-to-back sweeps starting
pitcher for the cut check in with the
professor and six and nine lifetime
against the pirates
a very good 3.18 era frazier a 478
career hitter against kyle hendricks
hit out towards center and there's a
base hit so frazier
gets things going to get that hitting
streak up to 10 games now with a lead
off single here's kevin newman
that ball and you off the end of the bat
and that's gonna drop in so pirates will
take hits any way they can get them
kevin newman a walk here to load the
bases with nobody out in the top of the
first and jacob stallings at the plate
reaches for it and taps it and this will
bring home a run an rbi for stallings
frazier scores it's one nothing and eric
gonzalez will come up with second and
third and one out
gonzalez another
pop-up back onto the grass vargas has it
runners will hold two down
hendricks hoping to scoot out of this
inning with just the one run in wilmer
defoe one for six
swinging a fly ball out to center and
mariznick dives
shy of the ball i don't know what
happened and newman and tom will score
defoe has a two run single the pirates
lead three to nothing he's hurt hit the
deck and laid flat on his stomach now he
gets up walking slowly toward the cubs
dugout area he's done for the day
peterson goes into left and chris bryant
will move over to setters todd frazier
has a two-out hit to prolong the inning
and the pirates have something else
brewing for troy stokes jr who is making
his big league debut
swinging a soft ground ball he can run
fast on the short vargas quickly unloads
and he is safe the ball gets away
defoe's in to score frazier gets all the
way to third the pirates lead
four-nothing here in the first and
they're going to face left-hander tyler
anderson tyler anderson coming off one
of his better starts in his career
carried a no-hitter through and i
believe it was into the seventh
to center field not going anywhere good
strong wind blowing wilson contreras the
batter
swinging lighter caught at third by eric
gonzalez for the second hour and here's
anthony rizzo and a swing of the ball
line to right right at stokes and the
inning comes to an end so a nice ten
pitch inning one two three go down the
cubs four nothing pirates as we head to
the second as chris bryant is at the
plate
and brian is going to have a stand-up
double
he crushed that ball to left that's out
number two on the play bryant goes to
third and here is jack peterson jack
peterson had not anticipated being
in the batter's box this quickly on for
the injured jake marissnik
then that'll do the trick
run batted in for jack peterson and it
scores brian cubs are on the board
a little morale booster for the home
dugout the quick outs after the lead off
double and peterson saves the day he'll
demoral vargas at the plate oh two a
swing and a miss let up pitch and struck
him out and the inning ends cubs get a
run on two hits strand of man through
two innings out at wrigley field base
hit for eric gonzalez so the pirate's
fifth hit today wilmer defoe in the fly
ball to shallow left center field and
this time he drives one to right field
near hayward and off the brick wall and
bounces away from hayward that will
allow joey cora to wave home gonzalez
and into third base with a trip
trip
triple goes wilmer defoe and the pirates
get that run back even if you don't get
anything more out of this just getting
that one run back it's a big deal
hard ground ball by todd frazier that
trickles past vargas defoes in to score
and the pirates lead 6-1 e5
matt duffy charged with the error bottom
of the third 6-1
report on jake bariznick a right
hamstring strain as he was trying to run
down a fly ball out to left center back
in the first inning replaced by jack
peterson so tyler anderson gets his
mount opponent duffy flight out in the
first and a foul tip struck him out
challenged him with a fastball that's
the second down to wilson contreras he's
coming up swinging a miss late on that
up and in fastball anderson strikes out
his first two men of the day a one two
three third fourth coming up and that is
the second out tom coming up
the other way yes
and into second base at least
two and a double for kai tom yeah the
pirates finding a way to
collect their seventh hit already
against kyle hendricks the batter is
jacob stalling high pop-up shallow
center
vargas is right there and it's going to
go to boaty in fact bodhi a big fan of
pancakes with chocolate chips we
understand makes the catch and that ends
the inning runners on the corners here
with one out the batter is jason hayward
high chopper back to anderson
and that will get rizzo in
coming in to score rizzo safe but second
is bryant it's now a six to two ball
game bryant the runner at third peterson
now two for two in the game and let's
see it ill tomorrow vargas and drive in
another run
swing in a fly ball by vargas out to
left tom shades his eyes from the sun he
makes the catch
in the inn against cubs get a run on two
hit strand two through four out at
wrigley field the pirates six and the
cubs two two on two out for the pirates
here in the top half of the fifth the
pitch is swung on and missed gets by
contreras picks up the ball and slings a
fireball to rizzo at first strikeout two
three so that ends the top half of the
fifth inning two down here in the bottom
of the fifth wilson contreras against
tyler anderson
come back here knocked down by anderson
he throws onto first to get the final
round one two three inning sixth coming
up from chicago and uh there's one out
chris bryant is coming up
brian hits one down the right field line
stokes calls everybody off slides and
makes a catch right toward that wall
where there is no foul ground stokes
makes an excellent catch and right for
the second out what a catch so two outs
quickly
it looks like he's going to oh nice play
slick right on the money gonzalez will
go to the seventh in chicago one away
jack peterson coming up
how about that
that's the second out he really knows
how to pitch one more out to get for
seven full
hit on the ground to short newman nice
scoop and on to first for the out
another quick getting for tyler anderson
two runs through seven innings for
anderson and the bucks will go to the
eighth tyler anderson started this game
he's still in there and 85 pitches faced
lefty walters
struck him out looking five strikeouts
for
tyler anderson and 11 in a row retired
by the lefty for tyler anderson he might
be down to his final pitch of a great
afternoon he's retired 12 in a row
swinging a miss he struck him out he
threw the fastball by him
and how about tyler anderson today eight
innings
and he does not allow a hit after the
fourth and will go to the ninth with the
pirates leading the cubs six to two
pirates uh in front but the cubs have
two on with one out and derek shelton is
going to call on his closer richard
rodriguez so nick martini is on to pinch
hit here for jason hayward and swinging
a miss he struck him out richard
rodriguez fans martini it's up to junk
peterson to keep the cubs going
base hit up the middle
score bryant rounding second
then heading for third and peterson
delivers again his second rbi of the day
and he will extend it to get the tying
run to the plate vargas nothing for
three but he does have some power
swinging a line drive down the right
field line that's gonna be a base hit
it's gonna go all the way to the wall
one run is in rounding third is peterson
he's gonna score it's a double for
vargas
and the cubs are down by only one it is
six to five it's not over yet tying run
at second two down bottom of the ninth
inning heavy drama javier baez stands in
a walk off on mother's day for buyers in
2016.
bouncing ball right side frazier to
fraser raised the jolly roger well rich
rod finally gives up a run but gets the
save as the cubs score three the pirates
come away with a victory on mother's day